si l'épidémie coronavirus est au coeur
des préoccupations depuis plusieurs mois
la grippe devrait faire son apparition à
la faveur de l'arrivée du froid
la campagne de vaccination a d'ailleurs
débuté il ya une semaine sur les
chapeaux de roues plus de 5 millions de
vaccins ont déjà été délivrées sur les
13 millions de doses dont dispose la
france un contexte sanitaire inédit
pousse le public à risque est à risque à
se faire vacciner
mais ce succès provoquent des ruptures
de stock dans une grande partie des
pharmacies et le pays ne disposera pas
d'autres doses à moi d'en acheter à
l'étranger alors doit-on craindre une
pénurie de vaccins contre la grippe le
public prioritaire sera t-il les et
c'est l'objet de notre face à face et
pour en parler nous sommes avec bertrand
legrand médecins généralistes secrétaire
général de la confédération des
syndicats médicaux français 59 62
bonsoir à vos côtés à philippe besset
pharmaciens président de la fédération
des syndicats pharmaceutiques de france
bonsoir alors 15 millions de doses du
vaccin contre la grippe
traditionnellement utilisée chaque hiver
5 millions est déjà utilisée comment
est-ce que vous jugez la situation
docteur est ce que vous êtes inquiet
pour les personnes les plus fragiles
risque-t-elle de se retrouver face à une
pénurie de vaccins bertrand legrand puis
évidemment c'est un des premiers frères
chose qu'on avait annoncé le nombre de
vaccins qui ont été commandés ne
correspond qu'à un nombre de personnes à
risques estimées par la sécurité sociale
or nous chaque année on sait très bien
qu'on est obligé d'imprimer nos propres
vont parce que la sécurité sociale ne
connais pas toutes les personnes à
risque et que le rôle du médecin
généraliste dans l'identification des
personnes à risques est essentiel est
que jusqu'à présent depuis les années
que l'on fait cette technique de bons
ont chaque année nous sommes obligés de
récupérer des personnes à risque donc
identification même des personnes à
risques est insuffisante
la commande de nombre de vaccins est
insuffisante et la seule chose qui nous
a permis fin qui nous permettraient de
tenir
c'est d'avoir une stricte application de
la priorité dans les pharmacies en
termes de délivrance et c'est une vraie
question qu'on se pose aujourd'hui quand
on voit l'activité dans nos cabinets
puisque manifestement c'est pas
exactement le stricte application qui se
passe c'est pas exactement la stricte
application qui se passe philippe besset
effectivement dans les pharmacies c'est
parce que je constate en fait lécher
fois qu'il me semble remonter sur la
première livraison de vaccins dans les
vaccins sont livrés en deux fois
donc là nous allons en voir une deuxième
livraison qui va qui va arriver en début
de semaine prochaine et en début et en
début du mois de novembre donc ce que je
constate c'est que énormément de
personnes de la population cible sont
fait vacciner près de 6 millions à
à l'heure où je vous parle à peu près
92% des des personnes qui ont eu un
vaccin qui soit soit administrée par non
puisque nous administrons nous mêmes des
vaccins soient soient délivrés ils vont
se faire vacciner chez le docteur haut
parleurs infirmiers sont des gens avec
des bons nous avons eu peu de de
prescription médicale autres
c'est-à-dire des docteurs qui ont fait
des bonds sur demande de leurs patients
qui n'ont n'était pas éligible au bond
ont fait d'énormes ans assez peu nous
les avons nous en avons délivré
effectivement quelques-unes il faut
savoir que des personnes peuvent avoir
des raisons tout à fait légitime d'être
vacciné et c'est quand même un peu
incroyable cette année de devoir freiner
la vaccination pour des personnes qui
par exemple s'occupent de leurs patients
âgés leurs parents âgés au travail dans
des milieux où ils sont en contact avec
des personnes fragiles ceci étant ceux
ci devraient continuer comme ça c'est
une bonne nouvelle de vacciner une si
grande partie de la population cible
depuis des années nous n'arrivons pas un
plafond à 50 % de la population cible si
cette année nous arrivons à 70 75 % de
la population cible ce sera une vraie un
vraie avancée de santé publique et ça
marquera
un retour en grâce de la vaccination
dans la conscience de la population et
ça c'est très bénéfique surtout un
espace cultive du vaccin qu'ovide à
venir bertrand legrand vous vous l'a
constaté cette vaccination des 50% de la
population cible aujourd'hui dans votre
cabinet bien nous on constate plus grand
chose on est médecin donc on ne prescrit
plus le vaccin on injecte plus le vaccin
on ne régule même plus le vaccin donc
les quelques cas que je vois dans mon
cabinet sont essentiellement des enfants
qui
on peut se poser la question de la
véritable du véritable risque
alors certes il ya des enfants
asthmatiques mais très sincèrement j'ai
un petit doute sur la question ou des
personnes qui sont très angoissés et qui
arrive avec le vaccin déjà délivrés et
une fois qu'il est délivrée on va pas
leur envoyer aux pharmaciens la chaîne
du froid est rompue rond là on injecte
donc clair est clairement le bilan de
cette année sera apportée aux
pharmaciens très clairement qu'ils sont
à la manoeuvre aussi bien en termes
d'injection que de gestion du stock et
que deux choix des personnes à vacciner
et donc si on découvre que effectivement
il n'y a pas eu une suffisance dans le
nom madame je ne vous vaccinerait pas
parce que vous ne faites pas partie de
la population à risque et je suis désolé
de vous le dire mais je compte cherche
c'est pas d'empêcher la grippe de se
propager ce qu'on cherche c'est d'éviter
les hospitalisations de grippe qui
viendraient exploser littéralement le
système hospitalier donc au jour cette
année on a une vraie à un vrai enjeu de
santé publique
c'est d'empêcher les personnes qui
pourraient faire une grippe qui ferait
hospitalisés d'attraper cette grippe
donc de les vacciner
donc c'est un vrai problème et au vu des
30% que j'ai pu voir aujourd'hui qui
n'avait strictement rien à voir avec des
personnes à risque
très sincèrement je comprends qu'il y
ait une vraie pénurie alors philippe bès
philippe besset c'est vrai que là la
vaccination contre la grippe c'est
pourtant un phénomène qu'on maîtrise est
ce que les autorités ont finalement
suffisamment anticipé par rapport à la
situation inédite que nous sommes en
train de vivre
alors déjà déjà un point commun il faut
clarifier pour la population est pour et
pour mon confrère médecins les
pharmaciens n'ont pas le droit de
vacciner en dehors de la population
cible c'est la réglementation nous
n'avons le droit d' injecter le vaccin
car la population qui a un bon nous
n'avons pas le droit en dehors de la
population de vacciner nous pouvons
délivrer le vaccin mais le les gens
repartent avec le vaccin parce qu'ils
ont une prescription médicale ou voilà
mais nous n'avons pas le droit de les
vacciner nous mais c'est interdit donc
voilà ça ne se fait pas c'est un mois
une régulation de l'autorité de santé
moi ce que je dis c'est que il va
manquer
il manque très probablement je ne sais
pas parce qu'on verra à la fin
si les pouvoirs publics ont réussi à
trouver des vaccins en réserve
il ya des pays qui ont 7 8 millions de
vaccins en réserve dans les stocks
on va dire stratégique de des pouvoirs
publics donc ça on verra ça en fin de
campagne
et c'est sûr que ce serait quand même un
problème si des gens de la population
cible manquée de vaccins pour l'instant
je ne peux pas dire ça pour l'instant ce
qui est sûr c'est que la campagne des
marges sur les chapeaux de roues pour
donner un exemple d'une pharmacie de à
peu près moyenne qui est la mienne comme
çà çà çà çà éclair chez moi j'ai 6 ans
vaccin j'ai déjà épuisé ma première
commande de 300 vaccins uniquement à la
population cible et j'ai 300 vaccins qui
vont arriver lundi prochain
et sur ces 300 g 120 déjà réservation de
vaccins c'est à dire des gens qui
m'amène leurs bons et qui me dit je veux
réserver le vaccin pour la semaine
prochaine
donc effectivement quand j'aurai épuisé
ses 625 je ne pourrai plus un recommandé
d'autres
à moins que l'état on trouve pour la
question réelle c est ce que il y a des
stocks stratégiques en plus des 13
millions de deux qui sont donnés
d'officiers cette question des stocks
stratégiques
elle vous inquiète bertrand legrand bat
comme le dit mon collègue d'ardeur tout
d'abord je tiens à préciser que je suis
ravi que le pharmacien injecte le vaccin
ça me fait un travail de moins puisque
moi je ne facture pas et je le rajoute
en plus de ma consultation
donc je suis absolument ravi que ce
travail me soit déchargée la deuxième
chose pour être très clair on va être
assez simple la délivrance doit être
rompu
et s'il ne doit pas y avoir de
délivrance à des personnes qui viennent
sans ordonnance ou sans avoir le bon
fait par le médecin a fait état en gage
la responsabilité du médecin quand on
fait le bon ça engage aussi la
responsabilité de la sécurité sociale
quand elle ne délivre pas le bon à des
personnes à risque je voudrais bien que
cette responsabilité soit aussi misé sur
la sur la table et nos confrères sa
masse et pharmaciens se doivent de
refuser la délivrance
parce qu'une fois que la délivrance est
fait nous ne pouvons plus faire
autrement que d'injecter se gardent ce
vaccin n'ira pas à une autre personne or
nous savons dès aujourd'hui que nous
savons pénurie ça sert strictement à
rien de tourner autour du pot
l'état n'a pas commandé assez de vaccins
puisqu'il a commandé sur la base des
personnes à risque il a identifié
or il n'a pas la bonne liste et chaque
année ils se trompent de plusieurs
millions donc c'est pas possible
philippe b c'est qu'on continue à pad
ordonnance vous appelez vous en tant que
pharmacien a refusé finalement vaccin
oui oui c'est ça a été précisé par par
une lettre du ministre en date du 14
la date la lettre du ministre qui
précise la consigne et la haute autorité
de santé date cette année donc du 14
octobre et elle est publiée au bulletin
du site officiel au vendredi c'est donc
depuis cette date là c'est très clair
nous devons refuser le vaccin donc à la
date du 16 octobre avant ce n'était pas
ce n'était pas par le risque de pénurie
est qui qui qui provoque et la
priorisation c'était comme ça et
expliquer tout à l'heure le fait de ne
pas surcharger les urgences
hospitalières par des patients fragiles
qui aurait pu avoir la grille en même en
même temps que les pee wee que vit deux
choses à dire quand même
l'année dernière nous avions 11 millions
et demi de deux mondes en avons détruit
600 milles c'est à dire que nous n'avons
pas pu injecter plus de 11 millions 2,2
à la population à risque quelle quelle
qu'elle soit et je pense que c'est
environ 20 millions de français qui dans
la population à risque à peu près et
vous voyez nous avons réussi à injecter
environ 2,2 cette année nous avons
commandé 13 millions de doses je ne sais
pas s'il est pas arrivera en avoir en
plus ou pas ça c'est le le mystère que
nous aurons que nous éluciderons à la
fin de la campagne
mais si nous avons si nous arrivons à
injecter 13 millions 2,2
c'est une bonne nouvelle je le redis
tinera cia nous arrivons à injecter 2
millions de plus de deux que l'année
dernière
noël donc ça s'est lassé de ce message
que veut faire passer jean passera un
autre c'est que les gestes barrière ça
fonctionne comprend la grève les masques
le lavage des marins les la
distanciation ça fonctionne aussi contre
contre la grippe épreuve années la
situation qui est que nous avons qui a
qui s'est produit dans l'hémisphère sud
l'hiver dans l'hiver austral
nous avons constaté cette année qu'il
n'y a pas eu d'épidémie de grippe est
notamment liée aux gestes barrières donc
voilà c'est le les messages à fait
simple que je pourrais donner pour les
gens qui sont plus qu'ils n'ont pas de
bons et qui ne qui donc ne rompt pas de
vaccin cette année il faut qu'il
respecte les gestes barrières pour le
coc vie mais aussi pour l'agglo et j'ai
eu 20 de nos données 1-1 ce coup c'est
que les gestes barrière ça fonctionne
aussi contre les gastro-entérites
bertrand le vent le mot de la fin vous
rejoignez les propos de votre confrère
au pharmacien
pas tout à fait les gestes barrière
fonte essentiel bien évidemment et c'est
pour ça qu'il est essentiel de voir les
l'iphone air france appliqué gestes
barrière est très clairement je rejoins
mon collègue pharmaciens il va falloir
faire un point et un bilan à la fin et
voir si ce transfert de compétences qui
a été fait aux pharmaciens a prouvé son
efficience comme ça n'a pas été le cas
l'année dernière mais ce que cette
efficience soit faite sur la bonne
délivrance qui est le coeur du métier du
pharmacien et on espère tous que les
pharmaciens respecte leur coeur de
métier à savoir dire non quand c'est non
et 8 quand c'est lui merci beaucoup
bertrand legrand médecins généralistes
secrétaire général de la confédération
des syndicats médicaux français 59 62
merci philippe besset pharmaciens
président de la fédération des syndicats
pharmaceutiques de france